l'aterosclerosi è una malattia che può
portare alla morte e che può iniziare
durante tale condizione è un processo in
cui depositi di materiali grassi placca
si formano all'interno delle pareti
arteriose riducendo o bloccando del
tutto il flusso ematico
benché le cause esatte
dell'aterosclerosi non sono chiare
molti scienziati pensano che questa
inizi con danni alla parete interna
dell'arteria chiamato endotelio le
sostanze che viaggiano nel sangue come
colesterolo grassi e prodotti di rifiuto
cellulare si accumulano nell'area
danneggiata della parete arteriosa
le reazioni chimiche che si verificano
nella cumulo di materiale causano
ossidazione delle molecole di cole se
ciò avvia una risposta infiammatoria in
cui le cellule endoteliali sul sito
danneggiato rilasciano sostanze chimiche
con richiesta di aiuto in risposta i
monociti del flusso ematico viaggiano
verso il sito danneggiato lo stimolo del
colesterolo utilizzato converte i
monociti i macrofagi i macrofagi
inglobano e digeriscono le molecole di
colesterolo
dopo questo processo i macrofagi si
trasformano in cellule schiumose con
accumulo per formare la placca quando la
placca aumenta di volume la parità
arteriosa si ispessisce e si indurisce
nel contempo le cellule muscolari lisce
nella parete arteriosa iniziano a
moltiplicarsi
la maggioranza delle cellule muscolari
lisce si sposta sulla superficie della
placca queste cellule contribuiscono
alla formazione di un saldo cappuccio
fibroso che copre la placa
successivamente il passaggio attraverso
l'arteria si restringe a fino a ridurre
il flusso ematico e la quantità di
ossigeno ricevuto dagli organi che
fornisce col tempo il cappuccio potrebbe
erodere e aprirsi rilasciando la placca
nel fiore
la placca fluisce a valle e contribuisce
a formare un quadro che può arrestare
perciò una limitata fornitura di sangue
è disponibile alle aree intorno
all'arteria parzialmente bloccata
degradando e con un rischio di uccidere
il tessuto circostante